hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
werden
heute zeige ich euch wie ihr die
biskuitrolle mit herstellen kann und
dazu müsst ihr zuerst den muster tag
herrschte
und falls ihr eine biskuitrolle ohne
muster machen mal lass dir den teil
einfach weg und steigt da ein wo ich den
ganz normalen biskuit teig herstellen
und jetzt sage ich einfach wie es geht
für die muster creme braucht ihr ein
eiweiß 30 gramm zucker 30 gramm öl
lebensmittelfarbe und 40 gramm mehl oder
wenn ihr keine lebensmittelfarbe
benutzen volt benutzt ihr 20 gramm mehl
und 20 gramm kaka um die ganzen zutaten
gibt jetzt einfach in eine schüssel und
vermixt sie dann miteinander
ich habe mir jetzt mein muster auf
backpapier aufgemalt mit folien stift
und ihr könnt machen was ihr wollt und
die creme die muster creme und den teig
dann aber auf die rückseite spritzen
einfach damit die farbe vom stift später
nicht in den teig kommt den muster
trifft sich dann wie immer mit einem
spritzbeutel
vorne schneide ich wieder jetzt von der
spitze weg und dann spritze ich das hier
einfach so drauf
und dieses blockiert gibt jetzt auf ein
backblech und dann stellt ihr ist für
etwa 15 minuten in euer gefrierfach
damit diese masse fest wird und später
der teig männer draufkommt nicht dieses
muster verschmiert als 15 minuten
einfrieren
für den biskuit teig braucht ihr drei
eier und drei esslöffel heißes wasser 80
gramm zucker 50 gramm mehl 65 g
speisestärke und einen halben teelöffel
backpulver um den biskuit als
herzustellen gebt ihr die eier in eurer
rührschüssel da kommen die drei
esslöffel heißes wasser mit dazu und die
schlag ds schaue mich auf
da last jetzt währenddessen den zucker
einrieseln und schlag das richtig weiß
schaumig
das land soweit habt vermischt ihr
wachstum familie und speisestärke und
zieht es über diese creme und dann wird
es ganz kurz ein gerührt
danach bereitet ihr euer backblech vor
ich mag das meistens in seinem bug
rahmen aber normales papier ich geht
auch da kommt dann jetzt
dieses muster drauf und bei mir dann
eben noch dabei kam und dann kommt da
noch schnell dieser teig drauf und stolz
nur bislang aufpassen beim verstreichen
am besten schmeckt ihr das blech so ein
bisschen hin und her damit sich das
schön verteilt
derzeit bei 185 grad etwa 10 bis 15
minuten gebacken
nach dem backen sieht es dann so aus wir
müssen aufpassen dass ihr das nicht so
dunkel packt dann bricht nämlich der
biscuit zu schnellen jetzt entferne ich
kurz den rahmen und dann entferne ich
noch mein tag post und entfernt jetzt
noch das backpapier
und da wird der schriftzug jetzt nach
außen kommt muss ich jetzt noch einmal
drehen
ich lege mir her und
sofern sich das tool das backpapier und
mein business und jetzt rolle ich meinen
biscuit von der langen seite heraus und
zu lassen jetzt komplett auskühlen
für die füllung braucht ihr dann 100
gramm tief gefrorene früchte oder
frische früchte
ich habe jetzt hier nur himbeeren dann
braucht ihr eine tüte magazine oder eben
entsprechend gelatine 200 g schlagsahne
350 gramm magerquark und 50 gramm
puderzucker und einen esslöffel
vanillezucker und ich gebe gern noch
etwas zitronensaft mit dazu und die
tiefgekühlten früchte müsst ihr noch
aufbauen
das mache ich jetzt hier nebenbei bei
mittlerer hitze und sobald sie dann
aufgetaut sind werden sie püriert
ich gebe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
wasser
und dann kommt da die akademie wenn ihr
gelatin der benutzt also blatt gelatine
müsste sie von wasserquellen lassen
ausdrücken und dann einfach dazu geben
und bei gemahlener gelatine einfach mit
dem kompletten inhalt also mit dem
wasser dann hier reingehen wenn ihr mit
ak tina arbeitet müsst ihr das jetzt
einmal aufkochen und dann zwei minuten
durch kochen lassen und in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal die
klappe schlagen und dann so lange kühl
stellen
die sahne ist fertig wenn sie beim
kippen nicht raus läuft und die stadt
jetzt so lange kühl dirigent schön ruhig
damit nächste runde schon fest friends
weil keine kerne drin haben möchte
sollte sich sofort in mission mit der
athene einmal durch den speed streichen
aber ich finde so eigentlich gar nicht
so schlimm das kann man ruhig schmecken
dass das richtige früchte sind die da
drin sind und zwar ganz ohne früchte
quark sahne creme machen will lässt die
früchte einfach weg und kocht die ak
tine einfach mit dem wasser auf das
klappt dann auch ganz gut so dass man
jetzt zwei minuten und jetzt ständig
kurz zur seite und lass es ganz kurz
abkühlen
während die himbeeren jetzt noch
abkühlen mache ich schon mal den quark
strafklage sich jetzt diese flüssigkeit
ab ganz vorsichtig - auch schon mal
ausgefallen
das kommt dann hier rein da kommt der
puderzucker mit rein und der analyse und
ich gebe eben ganz gern noch zitrone mit
rein
graz ein spritzer und wenn ihr diese
himbeeren eben nicht dazu geht sondern
nur die ak tine oder gelatine habt ihr
so mit dieser klage mit der sahne eine
käse sahne creme und könnt da dann zum
beispiel mandarinen oder andere früchte
mit rat geben
das bietet ganz kurz ungerührt aber
wirklich nur kurze dass der zucker mit
dem quark vermischt wird
nehmt ihr euch die magazine ist seht es
schon schüßler abgekühlt und wird schon
dicker dann nehmt ihr euch einen löffel
vom kreis und berührt es schon mal hier
rein
das müsst ihr gerne machen auch weil
statine das verhinderter nämlich dass
ihr später so kleine gelatine oder ein
stückchen in das damen habt ihr dürfen
nämlich niemals die gelatine oder katina
direkt auf die kalte schweiß gegeben
jetzt kommt es hier rein und das
vermitteln und das vermisse ich ganz
cool
dann kommt als diese
ein untergehoben mache ich normal leben
im teich schauen
diese kann alle vier in der spülmaschine
und ich gibt es jetzt für ungefähr eine
minute ganz kurz in den kühlschrank
damit sie etwas fester wert die creme
dann rolle ich diesen tag auf da kommt
dann diese quarkcreme drauf die weiß
nicht mal eine minute im kühlschrank
müsste einfach schauen ob sie schon
genug studiert ist so dass ihr das gut
verstreichen sind das verteile ich jetzt
hier an dem einen ende mache ich immer
etwas merken
das wird nämlich der anfang und zum
schluss hin aber weniger dass es dann
halt raus läuft und jetzt wird es
aufgerollt da könnt ihr euch das tuch
zur hilfe nehmen
und das hier schön einrollen und ich
schlage es dann nochmal in dem tuch ein
damit es so zusammen festwirt und nicht
auseinanderfällt
ich probier s mal ob sich die alufolie
fest obwohl ich hier das ist in den
kühlschrank
so lange bis es eben verstört
die rolle war jetzt für etwa zwei
stunden im kühlschrank und danach könnte
es ja einfach anschneiden
das erste stück ist immer nett so schön
dass nämlich das netz für einfach
vernaschen und dann könnte einfach
runter schneiden und das schön anrichten
und jetzt möchte ich euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken wünsche ich morgen einen
schönen valentinstag und dann bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
also
jetzt filme ich habe gar keine zeit ich
muss meine frau jetzt filmen wie sie
dass sie auspackt
das heißt ich bin ein stativ
entschuldigung sehe ich würde zu allem
gezwungen
wahnsinn was ohne bilder fragt sich die
ganze welt wie hat sie das wieder
gemacht hat sally das wieder gemacht
das hat die letzte halbe stunde